an extrusion machine melts down plastic
pellets then forces the liquid plastic
through a round die to form line Oh cold
water bath cools and solidifies the
shape then heated rollers stretch the
line until it's reduced to three
millimeters in diameter the line is
wound onto large spools which feed the
machines that wind the finish trimmer
spools on the engine assembly line an
automated machine apply sealant to the
magnesium engine fan they place the
cylinder on an assembly fixture apply a
gasket then insert the piston already
assembled to the crankcase its
up-and-down motion
turns then they mate the engine pan to
the crankcase the sealant in between
making that connection airtight an
automated machine screws the components
together then closes off the exhaust
ports and pulls a vacuum to test the
seal if the engine assembly passes the
test it continues down the assembly line
they install a gasket the carburetor
another gasket and the housing for the
air filter then they install a baffle
which distributes air so that it enters
the air filter evenly
they attach a gasket under the muffler
and screw the muffler onto the cylinder
the gasket and sealant on the screws
ensure that only exhaust gases can
escape through the muffler next the
flywheel when it rotates magnets inside
produce an electromagnetic field the
ignition uses to set off the spark plug
that starts the engine combustion cycle
after mounting the clutch on the
flywheel they install the spark plug on
the cylinder this automated machine
simultaneously tightens the spark plug
the clutch and the flywheel to specified
torques by this point workers have
welded a fuel tank to the motor housing
they've also installed a trigger a
trigger release and a stop switch they
place the assembled engine into the
housing they also place the air filter
into the filter housing at the next
station they attach the other half of
the motor housing
a robot tightens the screws to a
specific torque then they complete the
trimmers power head by installing the
starter cover